اليوم في مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده نتكلم انه منذ بدايه شهر ذو القعده
بدات القوافل الحجيج بالتوافق الى مدينه
جده والى مكه والى المدينه المنوره عبر
المنافذ الجويه والبريه وكذلك البحريه اذا
تكلمنا فقط عبر مطار جده وعبر مطار
المدينه وصل اكثر من مليون احاج من الخارج
استعدادا لبدء مناسك الحج هذا العام
والعوده للاعداد الكبيره
والمليونيه الى ما قبل جائحه فيروس كورونا
نتحدث على اكثر من مليون حاجه اكثر من 380
الف حاج قدموا عبر مطار جدا نتحدث اليوم
من داخل صلاه الحج والعمره زي ما انت شايف
الان اعداد كبيره او بداوا الحجيج بالوصول
عبر قوافل اذا تكلمنا فقط على فيما يتعلق
باعداد الحجيج هم كلهم او جميعهم من حجاج
الخارج زي ما انت شايف قوافل بدات تتواف
نعم الى مدينه جده في بعض متوجه الى مكه
مباشره لاداء طواف القدوم والبعض يا عادل
وراويه يتجه الى المدينه زياره المسجد
النبوي غير اليوم الرحله تستغرق من هبوطه
الى وصول الحاج الى الحافله فقط 15 دقيقه
حيستقبلونهم شباب وشابات سعوديات نتحدث
على اكثر من 220 كونتر جوازاتهم زي ما
احنا شايفين الثلاثه والاعداد بتتماشى
بشكل جيد جدا طيب لديك موضوع اخر ايضا يا
سلطان السعوديه والنمو الكبير للربط الجوي
الدولي ايضا يعني موضوع متعلق بالطيران
وانت في المطار حدثنا عن التفاصيل
بالفعل في هذا السياق نتحدث انه السعوديه
تقدمت للمرتبه 13 بمؤشر الربط الجوي
الصادر عن الاتحاد الدولي لنقل الجوي
اياتا في 23 بعد ان سجلت السعوديه اعلى
مستوى نمو بالربط الجوي الدولي قطاع
الطيران بالعالم هذا العام طبعا يشير هذا
التقدم الى استمرار العمل لتحقيق مستهدفات
استراتيجيه الطيران الوطنيه في السعوديه
وتنميه هذا القطاع مؤخرا انطلقات او كان
هنالك اعلان الرؤيه او الهويه البصريه
لطيران الرياض الذي يستهدف 250 وجهه بحلول
عشرين الثلاثين فيما يتعلق بالقطاع الجوي
نهض نهضه كبيره وانتعش بعد ازمه جايه حتى
فيروس كورونا التي حلت بالعالم اليوم تعود
قطاع الطيران في السعوديه الى نمو بشكل
كبير وتقدم في المراتب بشكل كبير جدا وينك
يا سلطان خلنا نشوفك اول شيء ونقول لك
شكرا
لسلطان السلمي
الوثائقيات وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات